[Music]
everyone is lured matching here at lords
of gaming dotnet I'm here with Vlad talk
about hazel sky so we go for us
hey so hazel Kai is the newest game we
just signed we announced it a few days
ago
it's an action-adventure puzzle game
from third-person perspective I need to
set in the future dystopia where
technology and art collide so engineers
they build a separate city and they try
to destroy all the art and artists and
you wake up on a deserted island as a
young engineer and you want to build
first a plane to get to the next island
and then that's why that's how you
progress for the game going from one
area to another and the final stage you
get to the Gideon City of Engineers
perfect so what was inspiration behind
this gameplay design well what he tell
us about the game work what we're seeing
right now on screen where we have a song
so you wake up and you find yourself in
this abandoned house and the letter from
your dad telling you to pursue your
dreams if you become one one to become a
real engineer so step-by-step in the
story you're trying to figure out what
happened you'll find like dead bodies
abandoned structures and you have to go
scavenging and find pieces so you can
make an airplane so you can fly over to
the next island because you got a radio
signal and there's another person on the
island talking to you guy who seems very
story heavy - yeah it's very story
focused there's no not much action going
on it's mostly exploration solving
puzzles and they're building things
wonderful so it's all about the art
style - because it's a full 3d scale
were looking at yeah it's building
unreal so the developers are from Brazil
this is their second game the first game
was blade and bones which was like a 3d
action Souls like fighter so this is the
second game and they're upping their
skills so it looks gorgeous
I would say the lighting is phenomenal
yeah they received their
they are also one of the people studios
who receive the Unreal dev grant from
unreal Epic Games
perfect perfect so do you have any
inkling so why is called hazel sky we
tried we tried so it sounds a little bit
what what what the player is doing on
screen right now so no he's trying to
solve a puzzle as how to use a big box
to get higher in the tower you need to
find your way out and then you do then
you will discover an airplane right now
so you need to finish building that
airplane to get to another Island
perfect perfect how many how many atoms
are in this demo have you seen anybody
reached the end of it or dis dem only
has one Island so once you finish
building the airplane you fly off that
that ends the demo but the real game is
longer the real game is actually about
six to ten hours long depending on your
puzzle solving skills perfect how far is
the team and development can they
expected to play in 2020 yeah it's
coming out in 2020 on switch PC Xbox and
Playstation perfect perfect thank you so
much for your time he predicts we need
super this guy there thank you this
lords lords of gaming here yeah I'm Lord
macho catch you guys later
[Music]